attention go hounds 20:19 was a year
that brought us plenty of sinister
thrillers and chillers so with thought
would point out a few creep shows that
really demand your attention get ready
to scream your hearts out because these
are the most disturbing movies of 2019
it's easy to forget now but just a few
short years ago no one really knew who
Robert Eggers was that changes overnight
in 2016
upon the release of the nerve shattering
gothic folk tale the witch a film that
comes highly recommended for fans of
arthouse horror after the witch fans
were eager to see what Sega's would
conjure up next including actors Willem
Dafoe and Robert Pattinson in fact they
both reportedly reached Alta Eggers and
expressed interest in jumping on his
next project whatever that might be
perhaps they regretted the decision upon
arriving on the set of the lighthouse as
the film's icy shoot in Nova Scotia was
reportedly a challenging one parents
make no mistake the lights house is an
extremely challenging film well we'll
keep our lips sealed and all major
twists and turns of the plots because
the less you know going in the better we
will say that this is a story about a
pair of lighthouse keepers who are doing
whatever they can to stay sane on an
increasingly mystifying New England
Island in the 1890s Edgar's latest is
undoubtedly one of the weirdest films of
2019 it may also be one of the best todd
phillips dark stylish joker finally
gives everyone's favorite supervillain
an origin story and a highly deserving
one of that in a standout performance
that's already drawing award nominations
joaquin phoenix plays arthur fleck a
social outcast who suffers from
narcissistic delusions all too soon
those solutions give way to horrific
bursts of violence the film is arguably
even darker than any installment of
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
calling to Minds gritty Martin Scorsese
classics like taxi driver and the king
of comedy
there's no arguing the Philips tale of a
deranged stand-up comic is hopelessly
bleak and critics spilled gallons of ink
writing about the film's excessive
violence but perhaps the most disturbing
aspect of Joker is how it succeeds in
holding up a funhouse mirror to our own
troubled times
beneath all the greasepaint the story of
Arthur Fleck is one you wouldn't be
surprised to see on the evening news
it's a timely cautionary tale and it
hits hard in the summer of 2018
ari Astor in the eastern holy horror
film hereditary upon unsuspecting
audiences and in the summer of 2019 he
delivered his latest experiment in
terror the fact that midsummer is mostly
set in broad daylight certainly doesn't
detract from the horror in fact in
several key scenes it is the horror
according to Astor Midsomer is just a
small film about an unhealthy
relationship that goes up in flames
and thus an apt description at least on
paper the doomed couple in question
visits a Swedish villagers Midsummer
Festival their adventure eventually
turns into a full-fledged waking
nightmare that gives a Wicca man a run
for its money soon enough they find
themselves hopelessly adrift in the
darkest margins of the occult we'll go
ahead and say it
this is folk horror at its most [ __ ]
up what is it it has special properties
what am I going through
of course mid soma is a breakup movie
only in the way that I read Atari is a
family drama and rest assured every evil
under the Sun is on full display here if
you've yet to see the film you should
know that it's often and Bera bleah gory
brace yourself for plenty of shocking
sites that you simply can't and see
popcorn not included this just might be
the scariest most hallucinatory film of
the year consider yourself warned with
depraved underground filmmaker Larry
Fessenden gives us a modern-day
retelling of the Frankenstein story the
plot is a very familiar one a determined
doctor cobbles together several stray
body parts to give life to an undead
something or other rest assured this
film is fueled by enough blood and gore
to satisfy even the most discerning
horror fan but thanks to deeply human
characters and an inventive and
insightful script depraved as far more
nuanced and affecting than you might
expect in my dreams someone else I owe
you something like a normal life in this
impressively twisted film even the
noblest intentions can be corrupted and
many monsters are often one in the same
one part monster movie one part
character drama depraved explores heavy
themes like post-war trauma and mental
illness but it remains first and
foremost a horror story of really messed
up one two years have passed since Andy
machete unleashed it's chapter one on an
unsuspecting public the film certainly
succeeded in scaring the bejesus out
audiences it also scared up 700 million
dollars worldwide at the box office
suffice to say expectations were high
for chapter 2 of this monstrously
frightening clown epic and we're here to
tell you that yes in chapter 2 is every
bit as unsettling as its predecessor
bill skarsgård absolutely mental take on
penny wise is still very much to start
the show though he's got some stiff
competition thanks to Bill Hader and
Jessica Chastain both of whom turn in
powerhouse performances it's chapter 2
definitely delivers the unbridled terror
that you so desperately crave and I'm
sup the emotional stakes at every turn
leading to quite a gut punch of an
ending
I craved you I miss you it's that rare
sort of horror film that aims to shock
you and pull at your heartstrings and it
succeeds brilliantly set in Paris in the
summer of 79 Yann Gonzalez's knife and
heart tells the story of an a filmmaker
who specializes in arty adult films of
the old male persuasion but just as AM
begins her most ambitious film to date
the members of her troupe start getting
killed off one by one she suddenly finds
herself smack dab in the middle of a
twisted heartbreaking mystery that
effectively turns her whole world
upside-down Gonzales delivers a lgbtq
centric truly unique slasher that pulls
no punches it's certainly not for the
squeamish but adventurous horror fans
will definitely want to take a look
wound sells a story of a cocksure French
Quarter bartender named well played by
army hammer after he takes home a phone
that was left at his bar his life begins
to get a whole lot weirder and when he
starts texting the stranger on the other
end and exploring the highly and
settling contents of the phone itself
things take a turn for the truly
terrifying as well and his girlfriend
Keary played by Dakota Johnson start to
unravel the mystery behind the
mysterious smartphone the film plunges
us deeper into a devilish and depraved
narrative that owes as much to David
Cronenberg as it does to HP Lovecraft
and we don't make those comparisons
lightly based on a bizarre and work of
true story those of chaos revolves
around a Serie C troubled Norwegian teen
who caught himself euronymous and
created what he called true Norwegian
black metal with his band mayhem in
attempting to bring mayhem to the masses
you Arnim us and his pals engaged in a
wave of shocking publicity stunts that
shook Norway to it's very core Mayhem's
live shows soon became the place to see
severed pig heads fire-breathing maniacs
and the bloody acts of self-mutilation
as Euronymous and his crew continued to
push one another the lines between act
and reality dissolve paving the way for
arson violence and death Lords of chaos
sells a story that feels way too strange
to be true but it's entirely based in
facts face part director Jonas åkerlund
allows the increasingly grisly tale to
speak
itself and he seems to take no
particular delight in presenting the
most shocking aspects of the case at
hand ultimately this is haunting
biographical drama about artistic
ambition run amok add Joby goes beastly
flick bliss to the lists of vampire
tales be claiming the genres menacing
grandeur even if the word vampire is
never actually uttered in the film sets
among the venomous vistas of modern-day
Los Angeles bliss finds a tragically
self-centered painter stuck in a
maddening creative block and in debt to
some serious shakers in a superficial la
art world in desperate need of
inspiration she turns to a powerful
hallucinatory drug and with a little
help from a soldier scalpel she quickly
spirals into a blood-soaked nightmare of
lust death and yes creation I don't know
something came over me and then it all
just started pouring out of me I don't
even remember doing it
the results are spellbinding ly sick and
twisted and unbelievably gory to boot
sets in Mexico amid the turmoil of the
country's violent drug wars Easter
Lopez's pitch black fantasy Tigers are
not afraid tell us a story of a little
girl named Estrella whose mother has
mysteriously disappeared one day to
soothe the Strayer after gunfire ass
outside a classroom a teacher gives her
three pieces of chalk and Cesar they can
magically grant her three wishes
accompanied by a band of fellow orphans
Estrella adjust to the perpetual dangers
of a new life and comes to realize that
those three wishes may actually be real
of course wishes rarely come true in the
way you expect the film is a pitch
perfect to relentlessly bleak chiller
thus as insightful as it is creepy
edgy emotional and deeply moving Tigers
are not afraid bored linger in your head
long after the credits roll some people
might not even consider Amanda Kramer's
lady world a movie at all it's more of
an experimental mood piece about the
fragility of human nature and social
structures after being cut off from the
world in the wake of an unknown natural
disaster a group of teenage girls are
going positively mad the film borrows
heavily from William Golding's 1954
novel Lord of the Flies
essentially moving the plot from an
isolated island paradise that are
suffocating confines of an apartment
rest assured you can look forward to
plenty of backstabbing and torture both
of the emotional and physical variety
you are a bad leader and we were never
friends
the claustrophobic photography and
wildly offbeat sound design is bound to
keep viewers very much on edge featuring
a stellar and sample cast this film is
definitely its own beast and that beast
has one hell of a bite it's safe to say
that sack Lepofsky and atom be Stein's
outrageous sci-fi film freaks is unlike
anything you've ever seen before
and take our word for it this film has
plenty of surprises in store for you so
do your best to avoid any spoilers
before giving you a look think you
already have a good sense of what freaks
is all about because you watch the
trailer think again
freaks is a story of a bald little girl
played by newcomer Lexie Coker who's
been raised in captivity by her
overprotective father played by Emile
Hirsch when she tries to make a break
for it she soon discovers that the world
isn't all what she thought it was in
fact it might be a far more dangerous
place than she could have ever imagined
you could buy any flavor you wanted with
that taste any flavor you check out one
of our newest videos right there plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]